[Music]
welcome back
so today i'm really excited to tell you
about a new
kind of emerging field of machine
learning where we're essentially
learning coordinate systems and dynamics
at the same time for complex systems so
especially i'm going to talk about deep
learning to discover coordinate systems
where you can get simple
or parsimonious representations of the
dynamics in those coordinates
okay so in particular i'm going to
mostly be talking about autoencoder
networks
so here you might have some high
dimensional state x
that describes your system maybe this is
a video uh
you're you're recording your system and
you're trying to learn the dynamics
uh maybe of a pendulum swinging or of
you know some phenomena you're trying to
observe
and with deep learning we're going to
essentially discover
a coordinate embedding phi and a decoder
psi
so that you can map into a latent space
z that has kind of the minimal
essential information that you need to
describe your system
and specifically we're going to try to
learn these auto encoder networks
so that we can represent the dynamics
in that latent space very efficiently or
simply
okay so in this latent space z
again that's like the minimal
description of your system
uh through this autoencoder network
we're looking for a dynamical system
z dot equals f of z where f is as simple
as possible
and so this is really an important dual
problem so on the one hand you have uh
the coordinate system discovery the
the fee and psi coordinates and on the
other hand you have the dynamical
systems discovery we're trying to learn
this efficient model
f that accurately describes how this
system evolves in time
so i'm going to walk you through a
number of key architectures for how
you can do this with deep learning uh
what restrictions we can put on
f and phi and psi and also tie this a
little bit to
kind of the history of coordinate
discovery and dynamical systems
okay good and i think this is a good
example kind of motivating what we would
like to do
so maybe we have a video of some complex
system in this case this is just a
pendulum in my lab
and what you would like to be able to do
is from this you know movie
or this you know megapixel image that's
evolving in time
you would like to be able to discover
automatically without a human expert in
the loop
that there is a key variable theta
that describes the system the kind of
minimal descriptive variable
for the motion of this pendulum is the
angle theta
and you'd also like to just discover
that the dynamical system
governing the motion of this pendulum
the evolution of theta
is given by a simple differential
equation here
so that's kind of at a very high level
what we'd like to be able to do
my colleague nathan kutz calls this
gopro physics
sometimes so you'd like to be able to
have you know just a movie watching the
world
learning the physics learning you know
how clouds are evolving learning how
pendulums swing
things like that learning how balls drop
according to f equals ma
okay so that's kind of what we want to
do but this is a difficult task to learn
these coordinates and to learn these
dynamics
good and so you know i'm going to zoom
out a little bit and talk about just
kind of general challenges we have when
we model dynamical systems x dot equals
f of x
again most of the world around us is
dynamic it's evolving in time
and in space whether you're thinking
about a fluid flow
or an autonomous vehicle the state of
your brain
you know your collection of neurons a
weather system
or a disease model these are all
dynamical systems that
change in time according to some rules
on the right hand side some physics f x
and so the big challenges that we have
one of them is often we don't know
this model f of x we don't have a good
model
for the dynamics so we need to discover
that model in the case of the brain
that's a good example non-linearity is
another key challenge so
even a small amount of non-linearity
really hampers our ability
to simulate estimate predict and control
these systems in the real world from
limited measurements
and again this is somewhere where
finding good coordinate transformations
can
make a big difference in simplifying
nonlinear dynamics
and the third challenge we very very
frequently face in the real world is
high dimensionality
times you know we do have this camera
this movie of a very high dimensional
uh pixel space or we have a simulation
or a measurement of a fluid flow with
you know
thousands or millions of degrees of
freedom and so
we want to essentially leverage the fact
that patterns exist in that data
to find those low dimensional
representations those kind of
autoencoder coordinates i showed you
so that we can discover the dynamics and
maybe even handle some of the the
non-linearity
okay so that's kind of a very high level
overview of some of the things we want
to do
with these autoencoder networks
okay uh and again you know i'm going to
use the example of fluids it's one of my
favorite examples
we know that even in very very high
dimensional systems like weather systems
or you know more classical fluid flows
even though
we would require hundreds of thousands
millions or billions of degrees of
freedom to represent these in a computer
or with our satellite images we know
that there are
low dimensional patterns and a few
degrees of freedom that matter
i really like this video here that shows
kind of this low dimensional pattern in
this very high dimensional system
and so i'm going to motivate these deep
autoencoder networks
more classically through the singular
value decomposition
okay so this goes by many many names in
different fields
singular value decomposition principal
components analysis proper orthogonal
decomposition but if you have some
complex system that you believe has low
dimensional patterns
you can essentially compute the singular
value decomposition of a data matrix
and you can decompose this this movie
into a linear combination of a very
small number of
modes or kind of eigen states that uh
capture most of the energy or variance
of this system
okay and the way i like to think about
this this is a data-driven
generalization of the fourier transform
this is essentially a fourier transform
that's tailored to this very specific
problem you're looking at the specific
data that you've collected
now in the uh lens of modern kind of
neural networks
you can look at the uh the svd or the
principal components analysis
as a shallow linear auto encoder network
where you have a high dimensional state
x that might be my whole flow field
stacked into a column vector and what
i'm trying to do is i'm trying to find
some latent representation some minimal
set of variables z
so that if i compress down to z i can
lift
back up to the original state and
recover as much information about that
high dimensional state as possible
so this is literally the u and the v
matrices from the svd
and this latent space z here would be
the amplitudes of these these modes
these pod modes
now in practice i would not recommend
actually using a neural network to
compute the svd it's way more efficient
to to compute it using a qr
factorization or some
kind of classical numerical linear
algebra technique
but as a as an abstraction we can think
of the svd
as a very very simple neural network and
so what we're going to do
is generalize this linear coordinate in
betting
and again this is a coordinate system to
represent your dynamics
we're going to generalize this
coordinate system by
making it now a deep neural network so
instead of
one latent space layer now we're going
to have many many hidden layers for the
encoder
many hidden layers for the decoder and
our activation units our nodes are going
to have non-linear activation functions
and so what this allows us to do is
instead of learning a linear subspace
where our data is efficiently
represented
now we're able to learn a non-linear
manifold
parameterized by these coordinate z
where our data is efficiently
represented
and often that means we can get a
massive reduction in
degrees of freedom needed to describe
this latent space
z good and so
this is kind of what this abstract auto
encoder network is trying to represent
usually i have many many hidden layers
in fee
and in psi and i have non-linear
activation functions
so the z parameterizes a manifold
okay good and we can learn these
essentially
by constructing this architecture you
know in tensorflow or pi torch or
whatever neural network training
framework you like and essentially
cooking up a loss function
so that we want the output minus the
input
to have the smallest error possible
given that we've choked down the
information to maybe three
kind of latent variables in z okay so
you fix the number of latent variables
you fix the architecture
and you train this so that it minimizes
the error between the output and the
input
and it learns then the latent features
of that input
and so like i mentioned earlier what
we're going to do now is we're going to
be training these autoencoder networks
not just to represent the data in
x efficiently but also to be able to
predict
how the dynamics and that latent space
evolve
accurately and efficiently forward in
time so now we're going to be learning
not just the encoder
and the decoder but we're going to be
learning a representation of the
dynamical system
f that evolves the system forward in
time
and this is becoming a big deal in the
machine learning community
because now we're able to start
understanding kind of the physics
of how our movies or our high
dimensional inputs are evolving in time
and i like to give this example i think
this is an extremely
kind of motivating example where what
you have here this is
this is a great visualization of the
geocentric
view of the solar system so the blue dot
is earth
the yellow dot is the sun and the red
dots are the other planets in the solar
system
and if we have kind of a naive
coordinate system where the earth is at
the center of the solar system
then you see that you actually get
extremely complex dynamics these are you
know really really
complicated circles on circles and
there's no
obvious simple law that describes the
motion of all of these bodies
in this coordinate system but if we
change our coordinates
so now we put the sun at the center of
the solar system and every other planet
is going around the sun
now this becomes a much much simpler
dynamical system
and this is amenable to discovering the
basic laws of physics
f equals m a kepler's laws of motion
okay
and so i think that this is an extremely
motivating example that shows
that when you have the right coordinate
system you have some hope of learning a
dynamics
f that's simple i could try to learn a
dynamical system that describes
this evolution here but that
differential equation is going to be
much more complicated
harder to interpret and understand and
generalize
so getting the right coordinate systems
is often essential
to learning the right dynamics and
that's been born
true over and over throughout the
history of physics
okay good so that's what we're trying to
do here we're going to learn the
coordinate system
that simplifies the dynamics and now i'm
going to walk you through a few examples
of how we've been doing this
and what some of the challenges and
opportunities are
so one of my favorite networks here is
one that was developed by kathleen
champion
when she was a phd student with nathan
and me and this
is essentially combining cindy or the
sparse identification of nonlinear
dynamics
to learn a dynamical system in the
latent space
of an autoencoder and i think this is a
really clever
network design so essentially what
kathleen is doing is she's learning
these
encoder and decoder networks these are
big deep neural networks
and there's additional loss functions
that we use in our neural network
training
so that the dynamics in z are
essentially a sparse
linear combination of candidate
non-linearities in a library
so we basically build this big library
of the possible terms that could
describe the dynamics in z
and then we essentially try to find the
fewest the sparses combination
of those terms that describe z1.z2.z3
dot
in the latent space and so to do this
kathleen had to introduce a number of
extra loss functions
to make this the cindy auto encoder
converge to the right solution
essentially um there's the original
reconstruction loss if you just remove
the dynamics in the middle
you still want your auto encoder to
faithfully capture
your data to find a good latent space
but then we have these additional cindy
losses
and the cindy regularization so the l1
term at the end
tries to make this set of column vectors
as sparse as possible
so we have as few terms in the dynamics
as possible
that makes it so that our dynamical
system is interpretable and simple it's
more like f equals m a
than some big complicated expression
and then essentially these additional
two loss functions
take different parts of this network and
make sure that if i compute
x dot here it's the same as if i took
z dot here and mapped it out and
things like that so essentially you can
compute chain rules on different
sub networks and make sure that the
dynamics the time derivatives across
those different pieces of the network
are consistent
that essentially makes sure that you
don't get into weird
issues where you just try to shrink the
z as small as possible which would in
principle also make
c small so this is a really cool network
that kathleen developed she was able to
learn lots of
very very sparse parsimonious dynamical
systems in these latent spaces
for complex systems and one of her
systems was actually
a movie of a pendulum a synthetic movie
of a pendulum
okay so uh this is a really nice way to
learn kind of those dynamics
and uh and coordinates but what if we
want to do more than just learn a sparse
non-linear model what if we actually
want to try to find
a coordinate system that actually
linearizes our dynamics
so we know from kupeman operator theory
that this is often
possible now there's lots of caveats but
there are often these special coordinate
systems fee
that if i take my original dynamics and
i map it into
you know the latent space through z i
might even be able to expect a
linear dynamical system z dot equals l
of z
now why would i want this linear
dynamics are
kind of you know generically solvable
with textbook methods
we can get optimal linear estimators and
controllers with you know one line of
matlab or python
so anytime we can make our system linear
we gain a tremendous amount
uh in doing so now the big big big
caveat here
is that this puts a tremendous amount of
uh
strain on the encoder and decoder
networks
so finding a coordinate system like in
the cindy auto encoder
where we have sparse dynamics that's not
that bad for the coordinate system
to do we can find a coordinate system
where there's a few
sparse non-linear terms this is related
to normal forms from dynamical systems
theory
but if we want to actually remove all of
those nonlinear terms and make the
system
truly linear that's a much much uh
stronger set of constraints that we're
putting on this this encoder and decoder
network
so generally speaking these are much
harder to train much more expensive
and these might be much nastier
functions fee to get these linear
dynamics but the good thing is just like
most of
neural network training this is a very
big expensive
offline training cost but once you've
found these coordinate systems you can
use them forever
online in a very fast and efficient way
you can do optimal estimation and
control
in this latent space once you've put in
the upfront cost of learning fee
now again this could be a deep neural
network with non-linear activation
functions
but it could also be a shallow neural
network with linear activation functions
in which case this kind of linear
dynamics auto encoder
would represent the dynamic mode
decomposition okay
so if if phi and psi were shallow
with linear activation units this would
essentially encode the dynamic mode
decomposition
so dmd has been used at length in fluid
mechanics and many other fields to get
linear representations of nonlinear
systems like these periodic fluid flows
and essentially dmd is finding some kind
of a linear regression model
on those svd coordinates i talked about
earlier okay and there's another cool
paper here that connects it to
coupeman operator theory so if you take
that idea of the dynamic mode
decomposition which is an extremely
popular
useful kind of general purpose linear
modeling technique
and you take this neural network
representation and you make those
encoders and decoders
deep neural networks with nonlinear
activation functions
what we're essentially doing is learning
a non-linear analog
of the dynamic mode decomposition we're
learning a nonlinear coordinate system
that'll take an original non-linear
system and make it look linear
and so that's exactly what many many
groups in the community have done in the
last few years so i'm showing you work
by bethany lush
who was a postdoc with nathan kutzen
myself this is her
deep koopman auto encoder where she
takes her input
and essentially through some some hidden
layers learns a coordinate system and
encoder where she can get linear
dynamical systems
again she looked at systems like like a
pendulum or flow past a cylinder
where there is a continuous eigenvalue
spectrum
so she needed to kind of add a few
innovations to this network to
parametrize these linear dynamics
by the frequency of the system there
have been many many other groups that
have developed
similar deep kootman autoencoder
networks
that essentially learn these coordinates
where your dynamics can be
simply or linearly represented
and i want to point out that those
different approaches to these kind of
koopman networks
or these non-linear analogs of dynamic
mode decomposition
come in many shapes and sizes and we
talk about this in a recent review paper
we wrote
on the coupeman operator theory this is
kind of a beast of a paper it's about
100 pages
and it's all about how you find these
coordinate systems
with neural networks and with other
approaches
and there's kind of two big philosophies
that the community has arrived at
one of them is the the kind of
constrictive autoencoder that i showed
you before
where you have a high dimensional state
you choke it down to
a lower dimensional latent space where
you can model the dynamics linearly
and then you can you know kind of decode
that latent space to your original
state x but what many people in the
community have also
done is take your your system state
and actually lift it to a higher
dimensional latency variable
z so you can take you know even if you
have a high dimensional state x you can
lift it to an even higher dimensional
state
try to model the evolution in that
higher dimensional state with linear
dynamics given by this matrix k
and then you can always map back down to
x and these are two very very
different philosophies of how you can
get embeddings that give you linear
representations of your dynamics now
i'll point out um
this bottom approach here is actually
much you know
this is reminiscent of lots of things
that people do in machine learning
already like
pooling and lifting kernel methods
often if you operate in a very high
dimensional space
non-linear processes can look more
linear so this is very consistent with
you know
existing machine learning literature but
i will point out
oftentimes these kind of constrictive
autoencoders
are more consistent with our physical
intuition that even in these very high
dimensional systems
there might be a few dominant coherent
structures or patterns that we really
care about
and we want to find out how those
behave and evolve linearly so these
constrictive autoencoders might be more
interpretable
you might be able to tease out
relationships when you are
working in a low dimensional latent
space z both
are valid approaches and i just wanted
to point out that you know lots of
methods explore both of these
architectures
and since i'm already here talking about
this koopman review paper i'll just kind
of
give a couple of teasers there's lots
and lots of stuff we talk about here
so the basic idea of koopman is that if
you have some original dynamical system
like this duffing oscillator with three
fixed points
you can essentially find new coordinate
systems or coordinate transformations
where you expand the region of linear
validity you kind of
expand where linearization is valid
through a nonlinear coordinate system
so here for example i might take my
local linearization around this third
fixed point
and i might find a local coordinate
system where all of the dynamics in this
p
pink region are approximately linear
another perspective of these systems
there are global coordinates
that appear linear like the the
hamiltonian energy
of this uh duffing oscillator so this
this phase portrait is given by a
particle
in this potential well here this double
well potential
and the actual energy level of the
particle
is itself one of these eigenfunctions
it's a hamiltonian
that behaves linearly in time the time
derivative of the hamiltonian is zero
times the hamiltonian that's linear
dynamics
and this fourth perspective here i think
is really cool um
and we're still exploring this you can
also rescale
space and time so that non-linear
oscillators like this oscillator here
appear to be more like linear
oscillators like
you know just sine and cosine pairs and
that
uh is something that henning henning
lang
has recently looked into is essentially
building deep neural networks that can
rescale
kind of time and space to make your
non-linear oscillators look
like a single linear oscillator and in
very complex examples like this shear
layer fluid flow
he's been able to find really really
simple low dimensional representations
that very accurately represent this
non-linear oscillator system
okay a couple of other examples before i
conclude
so those deep koopman neural networks i
was telling you about for ordinary
differential equations
craig gin and bethany lush recently
extended that to partial differential
equations
so we know that even for spatial
temporal
evolving systems there are often
coordinate systems
that will make them look approximately
linear
so for example in the nonlinear burgers
equation which describes the evolution
of uh
and formation of shock waves in fluid
systems
there is the classic coal hop
transformation
that transforms the nonlinear burgers
equation into the
linear heat equation and with our
koopman network
applied to partial differential
equations we can essentially learn
that linearizing transform in an
automated way without knowing any kind
of first principles physics
or having even having access of the
governing equations so just from data
we can learn these linearizing
transforms in
in pdes we also have a method
this is with craig gin and dan shea
essentially to find
these deep embeddings to discover
non-linear analogs of green's functions
and green's functions are very very
useful for
linear boundary value problems in
partial differential equations
and essentially what we can do is
through a very similar nonlinear
autoencoder network
we can learn these non-linear analogs of
green's functions
which would have lots of applications
and like non-linear beam theory or
you know aircraft wings that can deform
massively past where the linear
approximation is valid okay
so i want to just kind of tie this up
and conclude here
so we've talked about how there is this
joint problem
of learning coordinates and dynamics
this is
uh one of the most exciting areas of
machine learning research for
physics informed machine learning or for
physics discovery with machine learning
where oftentimes you know if i don't
know what the right coordinate system is
to measure my system maybe i'm looking
at the brain
or you know the climate system or a
disease system
i don't know what the right coordinate
system is to get a simple
law you know like f equals m a or e
equals m c
squared and so we can set up this dual
optimization problem where we're
simultaneously trying to learn the
coordinate embedding fee
to find a latent space z where the
dynamics in that latent space are as
simple as possible
i've shown you two examples one is where
f is sparse and non-linear using our
cindy approach
another perspective is where you try to
find a coordinate embedding where f
is actually linear this is a matrix and
both of those
are you know getting widely explored in
the literature
lots and lots of networks are being
developed to learn those embeddings for
lots of complex systems
so i encourage you to try it out and to
think of what other constraints you
might put on f
and fee and psi for example maybe you
have symmetries in your system and you
want
these embeddings to respect those
symmetries or you have some conservation
law that you know is going to be
satisfied like conservation of momentum
or
energy you know colleagues are already
building these networks that have those
baked in
and so there's tons of opportunity to
put partially known physics
into your system and to learn entirely
new system
system physics that we didn't know
before all right thank you very much